it's so great to welcome back to the
program today Lee McEntire who's a
research fellow at the Center for
philosophy and history of science at
Boston University also author of the
book post truth which we are linking to
today from the YouTube video for this
interview Lee it's so great to have you
back great thank you so much for having
me back
so a lot of what is in your book post
truth relates so significantly to what
we've seen in media and heard from the
federal government led by Donald Trump
about coronavirus over the last several
months we've seen everything from denial
to disinformation to cloudy data about
what is going on test results that can't
really be relied upon because we're not
really testing so let's sort of to open
the conversation how does your sort of
analysis that you do in the book apply
to what we're living through right now
well unfortunately it applies directly I
wrote the book the book is published two
years ago I had no clue about
coronavirus but at the end of the book I
predicted that we were in for a hard
correction from reality if we stayed on
the route that we were on Trump has been
running this playbook for a very long
time if you look at the things that he
was initially lying about the size of
his inauguration crowd whether he had
whether there were illegal voters and
he'd actually won the popular vote those
are things that are important but he
wasn't held accountable for them and
there you might say that in a way you
know that they weren't life-and-death
matters well we're now to a life and
death matter and I think what happened
is he got away with those kind of lies
what are they up to now 15,000 counted
through the Washington Post he he got so
used to it and you know the little boy
who cried wolf and here we are and we're
now getting that hard check from reality
where he's just learned that he can get
away with lying and distracting and all
the other things but we're now all
undergoing the consequences of that and
we're about to get within the next 10
days a very hard check from
one of the things that is sometimes
debated now is is it that fact don't
matter or is it that it's very easy to
get whatever facts you sort of want with
the widespread availability of both you
know liars and government and actual
propaganda news and so on with the
coronavirus thing it doesn't seem that
it's that facts don't matter it's that
it's very easy to find a set of facts or
supposed facts that say this isn't
really serious it's sort of like the flu
keep going to the beach
keep going to concerts all of this sort
of stuff it's it's going to pass it's
all under control so my instinct is it's
not that the facts don't matter is that
there's facts available for whoever
wants to find somebody asserting one
thing or the other thing as is
convenient what's your sense of that no
I think you're right I mean if facts
didn't matter they wouldn't be trying so
hard to spin the narrative or you know
look for alternative facts in in my book
I define post truth as the political
subordination of reality so it's not
that truth doesn't matter or that when
you say you're in a true post truth era
that's not to say that truth doesn't
matter that nobody cares about truth
anymore it means that we're living in an
era in which truth is endangered and the
thing that's endangering it is that post
truth is really a tactic that's used by
authoritarians and their wannabes to
control the narrative because that you
can control the narrative and the
information flow maybe you can control
the population and so it's a it's a very
dangerous thing that you know we can
read out in many different examples
there there are a number of different
examples we're now living through a
moment what I think that post truth is
particularly visible just because so
many people are paying attention so many
people are threatened by lies and denial
you know all of a sudden we're all on
the same boat and we're not just it's
not just that we're getting our
information from different sources we're
all seeing the same things happening in
our neighborhood what are some of the
strategy
you suggest people adopt to find out the
truth and to cut the risk of maybe
signal boosting disinformation I mean a
great example is every couple of days I
read or someone writes to me hey they're
testing chloroquine as a possible
coronavirus treatment and before i say
that to my audience i want to figure out
am i am i doing the equivalent of
spreading anti-vaxxer or am i reporting
on something that's really going on
what's the right process that you
recommend people go through to figure
out what's what's real it's it's tough
because the minute you report on a lie
you amplified the lie and cognitive
scientists have shown that people will
remember the lie they won't remember
whether it was true they won't remember
the source they'll just remember that
they heard it and so the thing that's
very important to do for anybody in the
media is when you're going to report on
false information they say the false
information is a story because a
prominent person said it I recommend
that what people do is follow the advice
of the psychologist George Lake Hoff who
said that what we need is a truth
sandwich you start off by telling the
truth then you report on the lie as a
lie and then you fact check it you show
why maybe the person was motivated to do
it and what's wrong with it so it's very
important for folks not to as you said
amplify false information because that
just puts it out there and then it it
goes and goes where are some of the
centers of of propagating so-called
alternative facts or or disinformation
outside of politics and politics were so
familiar with it an ideal to deal with
everyday coronavirus is exposing that in
medicine and of course quack medicine
sham medicine I think we may understand
that one but what are other sort of
centers of disinformation well I look at
it this way disinformation is created
for a purpose this information is not an
accident
so disinformation is created when
somebody has a financial interest or a
political interest or an ideological
interest in getting people to believe
something that isn't true so
when you say outside politics I don't
know if you're including Russia in that
because one thing that I found very
interesting for the last few days is if
you look at the Twitter handles that are
trending for the last several days new
Twitter handles in American politics
start to trend at around three o'clock
in the morning which is you know
amazingly well that's wake up time over
in Moscow so they're messing with their
politics they're messing with our
Twitter handles as we knew now examples
outs is saying you also mentioned
science denial I mean if you think about
what are the fossil fuel industries what
a big tobacco you know those sorts of
people with financial interests what do
they have to gain by creating
disinformation I mean I'm sure there are
other examples that I could give but you
know you you think of if you think of
the political and ideological examples
you think of the economic examples those
are really the big ones these days but I
think that anytime somebody is telling
you something that you kind of wonder
does that person have a stake in that
being true it should make you skeptical
when we are thinking now about what
needs to happen from here until whenever
we start to see a change in the in the
trends with what's going on with
coronavirus it seems to me that when for
example Fox and Friends says this is
actually a great time to fly the planes
are empty the airports are empty this is
fantastic there is actually a real human
risk particularly when Fox News his
audience skews disproportionately old to
perpetuating this stuff yeah what do we
do I mean what can we do it's that the
old folks aren't watching my show so I
have no access to them right so what how
do we manage this stuff it's it's
difficult I I heard tell that last night
Fox News all of a sudden started to wake
up a little bit and this Tucker Carlson
and a few other people started to say
you know you really have to get serious
about this and then Trump started to
take it more seriously talked about not
congregating in groups of more than 10
you know etc so you know that and we've
known for some time that there's a
little bit of a
feedback loop between Trump and and Fox
News I mean one thing that I've
advocated for a long time which is
particularly hard now that we're all
locked down I mean we're all sheltering
in place but the thing that I've
advocated is engagement people get
information from people that they trust
and so maybe they turn on the news and
you know do they trust what's coming
from the news or from political figures
that they trust maybe they do but they
also trust their friends and neighbors
they also trust their family and so I
think it's really important that we have
those conversations and there's a lot of
anecdotal information which shows that
that works in science miles say that's
how you get somebody to change their
mind about climate change that's how you
get somebody to change their mind about
anti VAX the trusting relationship is
the place to share that information so
you know we can't give up giving that
the truth out there is really important
is there any particular set of is there
a profile of the types of folks that are
more likely to open-mindedly reassess
their beliefs in the sense that you
might say well it's intuitive that older
folks are less likely to reassess their
beliefs because they've held their
beliefs for a longer period of time that
may be completely false right well are
there some of those characteristics that
let us build a profile of who is most
likely to be open to changing their mind
there's some empirical work right now
going on is I'm a philosopher I'm not a
social scientist so I'm not sure I'm the
best messenger for this but there is
some empirical work going on where
they're trying to measure whether or not
belief and say conspiracy theories
correlates with liberal versus
conservative worldview and the trouble
with this kind of researching is I mean
you can always think of exceptions you
can always you know think of examples
where you know well what about this what
about that um in in my own research you
know in the work that I've done on
science and I'll or not post truth I
haven't really noticed that you know the
old versus young you know rich versus
poor I guess what I I guess I'm
accepting this
as a fact we all have cognitive bias the
book by Daniel Kahneman called Thinking
Fast and Slow shows the cognitive biases
are built-in to all of us and so I think
it's dangerous to just say you know well
you know everybody who believes in
conspiracy theories skews right or
everybody who believes and you know
denial coronavirus skews old or
something like that for one it may not
be true for another I think it overlooks
the reality which is that we all have to
be on our guard against these mind bugs
if you want to think of it that way this
ability to believe something because we
want to believe but that's really the
danger so you know I I can get something
of an answer to this to say look at the
literature you know on this because
there is even with people working with
mmm our eyes on this which is really
interesting work but I don't want people
just to dismiss this as somebody else's
problem because post truth is
everybody's problem well medical stuff
and in particular anti-vaccine
terrestris party lines so when you look
at anti-vaccine the right who are anti
vaccine government trying to control
them they're distrustful of government
people on the Left say it's for-profit
big pharma trying to you know pump heavy
metals into us or whatever very
different political views but they end
up in some kind of strange strange
bedfellows sort of situation you're
absolutely right and the other thing to
notice about anti facts is that they
tend to skew more educated as well and
which is a really interesting thing
because you know you think of somebody
going you know baby being skeptical
maybe they're scared and then they go to
the internet and they start to do their
research and they maybe they find that
reliable information then they do more
research and you know we in the trade
you know going down the rabbit hole
right think of it that way but that's
the same way that flat earthers are
created right they get on YouTube they
start to look at the videos next thing
you know they they end up there so you
know it's it's really fascinating to me
that somebody can be very well educated
and still believe
some of these things and I think some of
what it has to do in the literature
bears me out here is that sometimes what
happens is as somebody's better educated
they're more able to defend and their
views you know you talk to some people
who deny climate change and you know
they can be really up on some of the
laters
literature what they don't know how to
do is to reason like a scientist they
don't know how to use that evidence and
that literature you know to to make the
important point not to cherry-pick not
to expect you know zero uncertainty
before they have a belief that's the
problem that they're really missing is
not you know some particular data point
that they can use to shove down your
throat but how scientists reason about
data very very well said we've been
speaking with Lee MacIntyre research
fellow at the Center for philosophy and
history of science at Boston University
the book post truth is out and you can
check it out using the link in the
description to the YouTube video for
this discussion Lee always a pleasure
having you on oh thank you so much I
really enjoyed it